[Music]
welcome to
ear biscuits the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting
i'm nervous again
of course you are man i'm nervous uh
we're we're doing what we
are doing what we said we would do which
is to give a one-year follow-up to our
deconstruction stories
and um we have talked about some you
know we've talked
on and off about uh our sort of
continued spiritual journey but
we haven't gotten into it specifically
and exclusively
in the way and also personally and
individually in the way that we're going
to do over the next two episodes
yeah um just to recap uh
one year ago from this release uh you
know minus a couple of weeks
we decided to launch our lost
years series where we explained
about our experience growing up in the
evangelical church about
being fully committed to our our faith
um you're already yawning is that it i'm
tired i'm bored of you
already man i know this is this is your
episode
i'm gonna let you do all the talking i'm
only gonna ask some questions here and
there
but when i do interject i would just ask
that you're not yawning my face
yeah i'm sorry i think it i think it
it's a nervous yawn
oh i'm sure it oh yeah i i on i feel
like i have to get more oxygen
okay when i get nervous so you're not
bored with me
no i'm just a little bit nervous okay
apology accepted
anyway what was i saying i was saying
that
we told our stories about how we you
know how we became
professional christians well you know we
we we were on staff full-time with
campus crusade we talked about all that
there were there were
two episodes just to go through all the
stuff in a
in a span of time from college
all the way through uh leaving our
engineering jobs and
and joining campus crusade until leaving
like
we filled in all of those gaps in our
career stuff we never talked about
before yeah
and then now we knew that that was
basically setting the table to then say
to go into more depth about each of our
spiritual spiritual
journeys and so at that time
uh you went first then i went second uh
and so we're just gonna repeat that
you're gonna go first again yeah
which i'm is that good or bad i think
that's good it's good for me i think
you're
you're breaking the seal you know um
we're different people
we have we we process we've gone through
so much of our lives
together uh but we process things
differently
and uh you know our
our friendship has stayed intact our
love for one another is strong as ever
and i'm here to support you today as you
give some sort of update i don't i don't
want to supercharge this
any any more than it is and i'm i'm
i'm curious how you've approached this
and how you've thought about it but i'm
i'm actually not going to ask that
question i'm just going to let you take
it from here unless you think there's
something else to fill in the gaps to
bring people up to speak no because i i
i will
in the course of what i'm going to try
to say
today i'll end up filling in some of the
gaps and
talking a little bit about this but
um yeah the only the only thing i'll say
to kind of
before i get started is that i have a
lot of notes
in the same way that i did when i did
like typically you know
this is not this is not a scripted
podcast this is just two lifelong
friends talking about life for a long
time
and we rarely if ever have any sort of
notes or outline that we're going off of
but whenever i talk about this and this
is the ironic thing is i just i want to
acknowledge this up front is that
you know when i was a christian when it
was in the church when i was a
professional christian there were a
number of times that i had to give a
talk
or even dare i say preach a sermon
i preached a couple of sermons in my day
i dare you to say it
and uh i
i find myself approaching these
episodes like i like i would getting
ready to give a talk and i don't mean
like a pr like a preachy sermon like i
but i'm just saying that like you want
to make sure that you got
all your stuff together
and so i'm going off notes as if i'm
giving a talk
and so i just apologize for the if if
the tone is a little bit
uh different or readier than normal but
i just feel like it's my way of getting
the right information out there
go for it ready at some point we'll
we'll stop and
have a little ad break but just keep
that in mind
okay so again a year has passed and
the way i kind of approach this is i
want to talk about some things that
uh as i've reflected on telling our
story
at the time that we told it how i've
kind of processed
uh both the the response but also
the the way 2020 unfolded
and then as i'm going to spend a lot of
time on that but then i will eventually
get to sort of
the update where i'm at spiritually it's
kind of what i'll end on
which we've touched on a little bit on a
few episodes but i think we'll get into
it a little bit more
deeply um
so going back to the initial sort of
like
laying it all out there a year ago
putting it out into the world
the the initial reaction um
very very supportive and encouraging
on the whole like i'd say the vast
majority of people even people who
disagreed
yeah were super supportive and
encouraging
but my response to
the minority of negative responses
was very informative about who i still
am
and how much growth i still have yet to
do so
um i you know we have both received a
lot of negative feedback doing what we
do for as long as we've done it
being in this totally democratic
platform where you can put whatever you
want to
on this place uh and have whoever wants
to say anything say whatever they want
to without any sort of check
and also with anonymity
we have i don't know
i don't we've never like talked about it
that much
but we have developed a thick skin i
mean let's just be honest
well i'm gonna i'm not gonna admit to
changing my hair style years ago because
i got fed up with the
comparisons to velma from scooby-doo
yeah was you thelma whatever
well because you look just like her and
i think it's velma
yeah and i kind of look like shaggy so
it's not that big of a deal
and you talk like scooby-doo
um but so we've got to pretty much
people will say anything and
everything that can be said about you
everything that can be said they'll
misunderstand you
and misconstrue lots of things that you
intend
as an artist as a creative person an
artist we do consider ourselves artists
uh we have created some art um but i
mean comedians
the talk yeah everything that can be
said about our videos everything
can be said about our our style of humor
everything that can be
said about what we look like every
aspect of what we look like every aspect
of our bodies our hands our feet
literally like literally like anything
that can be said about
any part of us has been said publicly
and i've just kind of gotten over it if
you think well that's probably great
then
you're not thinking about it enough yeah
but the one thing
that telling my story my deconstruction
story
in the fashion that i chose to tell it
that
one thing it invited that i have never
really experienced
is a critique of my mind
right so i chose to tell my story
which centered around sort of uh
it was a largely sort of the unraveling
of my
intellectual underpinning
when it comes to christianity right and
i condensed
about a 20-year process into 90 minutes
therefore it was not exhaustive um
and it was not meant to be a
dissertation
or some sort you know that was not what
it was meant to be but that was how many
people
interpreted it because
i told this story with these steps and i
used some examples and i actually talked
about some of the things that were
convincing to me
that sort of changed my view and so what
that did
naturally people poked holes in it yeah
but what you're saying is that
given the nature of the presentation it
was it was presented with holes in it
well i'll say two things it was
presented with holes so that
any sort of like hey let's take this and
break this down and show all the places
that he's wrong
is uh i wouldn't say it's a totally fair
way to treat it but i will say i mean
listen
i understood that by saying these things
i would be open to criticism and my
thought process would be open to
criticism even if you're seeing sort of
just snapshots of my thought process so
are you complaining about
no the point that i'm making is that i
was just reminded that like oh wow
you've actually grown a pretty thick
skin about what people might say about
the way you look or
what people might say about the things
that you do on the internet
but how funny you are you yeah i know
i'm not funny to a lot of people so
but what i've never done because i've
just been doing dumb stuff on the
internet for 10 years
is sort of said hey i'm putting my mind
out there in this way and have people
critique it
uh and critique my thought process and
that my pride
was wounded and i was just reminded that
i still got a lot of pride i got
i i have pride in the way that i think
about the way that i think
so ultimately i think that's a good
thing it's like if i can keep having
those edges
sand it off the feedback is a good thing
that's good for me personally
now you know you heard it
bring it on so one of the things that uh
now i know more so than you i've been
and again i think
a lot of this has to do with the fact
that a lot of the critique and a lot of
the conversation
about our stories was kind of centered
around my story because
i was i my story was much more open to
critique because it was
yours was very personal uh and who's
gonna argue with
your personal experience right you told
somebody
told a lot of stories and it was
personal it was super relatable and i
was kind of saying this thing that
is like here's the here's here's how the
faith began to fall apart for me
specifically so i have against my better
judgment
most likely um i've read some of this
stuff right
i've read the the blog posts the
facebook posts and and watched some
videos and
again i haven't watched anything all the
way through i've kind of gotten the gist
of some things um
but it generated a lot of content but
one of the other people
it did it did but one of the things that
i
i noticed was that it seems that the
sort of general evangelical
conclusion about us is that we were
never christians right
that's where the majority of
evangelicals have have landed that's
it's like okay this is how i interpret
this and this has been pretty
fascinating for me personally because
this is exactly what i would have said
about us
you know 15 years ago if i were to watch
and hear the stories that we told i
would be like well
i guess those guys were never christians
or
they are still and they will come back
to a full
faith and full relationship with christ
at some point in the future
and i was thinking about that uh and
thinking about
the way that i used to think about
things like this and it was very much
it was a commitment to christianity it
was a commitment to
the bible but more so than anything it
was
it was commitment to an ideology it was
commitment to a system of ideas
that yes have their roots in the bible
but me and you both came from a reformed
background
you like you came from like a specif
like your church was specifically like
hey we are reformed
and my church was like we're not a
reformed denomination but this
particular expression of this
non-denominational denomination
is reformed right post-college
newlywed the churches we were involved
in yes right so we so we
basically even though i was
uncomfortable with it i kind of
subscribed to
sort of calvinism light you know like
what john calvin taught so you've got
uh the p in tulip which is perseverance
of the sinks this is
deep cut for those of you who don't have
any experience with this at least you
skip to the piece
you know you but you left the thule on
the table that's good
essentially it's this once saved always
saved thing
that again there's biblical support for
it there's also some biblical
there's some stuff that might bring it
into question but the general sort of
consensus of
the churches that we came from and the
sort of the the part of the evangelical
church that we came from is that once
saved always saved
and so i just find it interesting that
you know you hear a couple of guys who
talk about
their experience with christianity how
they were all in for jesus
they recognized that they were sinners
in
desperate need of the grace of god that
comes only through accepting the
sacrifice of jesus on
our behalf and we made a decision in my
case multiple decisions just to make
sure it take it had taken
to accept christ and you say
those guys were never christians because
that is what you have to believe
the power of ideology um
but the the thing that i really want to
get into
is the timing of us telling the stories
so before you move on so i mean you're
obviously asserting and i will
i'll agree from my perspective too that
in experience that
yeah i believe i was
saved i mean period i don't know what
else to say
i don't look back on that experience and
and
you know i'm very critical of of myself
but i don't i just don't think that
yeah i i don't i don't look back at my
former stuff that way
and you if that's what you're saying too
you think you were as real as you you
could be i mean did we miss something
what i would not apply what i would say
to uh committed evangelical christians
who are listening
is the way that they feel about
their relationship with god and the way
that they experience their relationship
with god
is i would say as well as i can without
being in your own
without being inside your body i would
say i get it
i relate i understand i have the same
experience
and now i think very differently about
that and we would have fundamental
differences as to what we think was
actually going on at that time
but i'm saying that i understand that if
you subscribe to
if you're still in and you subscribe to
this particular ideology
you do not have a choice but to believe
that we were never christians or that we
still are and we will return someday
that's all that's all i'm saying so i'm
not i'm just yeah i'm just saying it's
interesting that that's where people
landed
and the power of you can actually
the way that it has been discussed in a
couple of places
the way that we have been described as
like you know you can kind of you can
you can kind of tell when you listen to
them that they never really
came to a saving faith they never really
repented they never really understood
grace it seems like it was cultural it
seems like
it was um maybe there was an
intellectual commitment but it doesn't
seem like they had given their hearts to
jesus
and as somebody who made those same
arguments to
lots of people who talked about it's not
about a religion it's a relationship
it's about
a great it's the gift it is the
undeserved
gift of god grace through faith that's
the only way
that's what i believe that's what i
lived that's what i experienced
uh and to be told no you didn't
i'm not mad at those people for saying
that i'm saying i understand that when
you
have when you've completely bought into
the ideology you have no choice but to
believe that
just an observation but the timing the
timing of our stories
what are the chances that we told these
stories at the onset of 2020
just before the world fell apart
uh and listen i'm i'm very grateful
that we were able to do this at the
beginning of what has ended up being
basically the most difficult world for
the difficult year for the world at
large in our lifetimes right
oh yeah uh some people have suffered a
lot more me and you have had the
the privilege of uh being in the
position that we are and having the jobs
that we are so that we were able to get
through this year relatively unscathed
a lot of people didn't and the world
didn't and the world is still suffering
um two two things about that
first thing is
having been open and vulnerable about
our spiritual journey gave us an
opportunity to then
speak open and vulnerably about
the things that happened in 2020 yeah
and you know two guys who have been in
the public eye for a really long time
who had kept
this most significant
thing seek secret and off limits
we kind of become experts at navigating
interviews
um without talking about the elephant in
the room which is like but weren't you
guys like christians and not just
christians but like big christians like
professional christians didn't you guys
write like some christian songs for kids
that were on like
dvds that were in constant rotation at
christian bookstores yes yes yes and yes
but not talking about that it was this
weird thing that as we continue to get
more vulnerable on this
podcast and just in life in general
uh continuing to
try to balance that not sharing that
thing and then
what became a year where there were
certain things that our nation in our
world
faced where the expectation was if you
are a public figure with
an audience at all you're going to speak
into these things like you can't really
get away
in 2020 you couldn't get away with just
staying on the sidelines about a lot of
things that we went through as a nation
yeah but boy it made it a lot easier
engage in that conversation having
gotten vulnerable
i don't it would have been weird to not
have had that conversation at the
beginning of 2020. i honestly can't
imagine our interaction publicly with
the year that was 2020 without having
told our stories
you know i'm surprised that
we're just as a this is a side note that
we were
that we've been as successful as we've
been
and gotten to the point in our careers
we have without
being vulnerable to that level because
that's kind of
a big part of being an internet
personality
we wrote a whole book that was about us
i mean let's be honest
we wrote the book of mythicality right
that was full of stories about us
it was memoir-ish but yet it didn't talk
about any of this stuff
and we weren't ready and i do think
there was feedback like okay there's
they have more to gain by
sharing this story than than keeping it
to themselves
and you know the people that are
suffering are the ones who are their
faith is
you know is not strong enough yet so
they're
they're they're they're capitalizing on
vulnerability for their own
um to to to boost their popularity even
further yeah
at the expense of people who are
floundering spiritually
and it's you know i'll talk a little bit
about okay so
we'll come back to that uh but
uh okay i'll just wait then if you're
gonna talk about it but um
but the but the the bigger significance
i'm grateful
that yeah to your point back on point
i'm grateful
that the timing worked out the way it
did that we were able to talk about that
and then it led to
the conversation we were in the episode
we had about ben
i mean was was we couldn't have had the
most i mean again
i just felt like it's so important the
biggest episode of air business and
that's not what this is about
but like yeah we had no clue there's no
clue that people were going to watch it
to the degree they did but it was
important for
us to to process that
and to make it for people to take it how
they would
for us to process that aspect of uh
our lives and how our spiritual journey
had an impact on
one of the most important relationships
we had growing up where there are other
best friends and we can talk all about
ben and ben's death
but to talk about ben's death without
talking about what we were trying to do
during his his with him on his deathbed
and trying to bring him to a decision
for jesus
in the way that we process that now
would have been a totally different
story
and yeah to be to be in this medium
and not be able to be true to yourself
will eat away at your soul
yeah and that's that's why i'm grateful
for it yeah
and it i mean it feels
i don't know i could i would have
exploded yeah
i would have exploded i feel emotional
about it just because i'm
i'm i'm grateful i mean it's uh
i i got a lot to process in the next
episode i'm not gonna
but uh i i'm i'm grateful for it and
yeah
everything that we've gone through as a
world and as a nation that i
you know i'm i'm grateful that we
were able to bring more of ourselves to
that than
before the lost year series we were i
felt like we were ready
or are capable or had the
had the confidence to do yeah right
um but i think that the bigger
significance
for me was the way that
my story in us telling our stories
intersected with the evangelical
church's response to 2020 in general
okay and uh i am going to spend a fair
amount of time
talking about that today but first oh
god
let's sell a feel-good mythical morning
hat
um this is a cool hat
i mean if i put it on i'm just going to
look stupid because i don't want to mess
up my hair
oh is that is that what that's what
matters most okay let's not forget
that uh feel good mythical morning it
comes on a hat it comes on a hoodie it
comes on a shirt it comes on all types
of things
i think that's called a six panel this
right here my friend
is i'm super proud of what this
represents feel good man
that if you get you watch good mythical
morning it feels good do it i don't care
what you're saying i don't know i don't
think it feels good dude i don't know
i don't care who you are i don't care
where you are if you watch good mythical
morning i believe
that you will leave feeling better you
might feel nauseous
but you will feel so much better in
other ways that it'll counteract it
and that's why we want to put it on a
hat and why you might want to wear it on
a hat or a shirt or a hoodie because
uh good mythical morning makes you feel
good
and fitting no matter who you are what
you believe
yeah and fittingly this stuff does feel
good i mean i don't know about that hat
but like the hoodie
feels really good like we we pride
ourselves on soft shirts and hoodies
sweatshirts i'm just saying we want
things to feel good why else wear
something if it doesn't feel good
mythical.com
okay my story in a nutshell
just to set the stage grew up in a just
in case you have
you just decided to not go back to the
original why wouldn't they do that
i think they need they'll do that okay
go ahead go ahead grew up in a christian
home
made my own decision for christ at a
young age
starting in high school got very serious
about my faith
along with this guy right here which
continued through college
then after got involved with campus
ministry then after college we
eventually went on staff with campus
crusade to train students in evangelism
now my understanding growing up and also
well into adulthood was that
what the church believed which was
largely based on
what the bible said was true
and many things that the world
those outside the church thought
um the things that they thought were
true were actually lies right so what we
had
inside the church was the truth and what
the world had
was lies and more specifically when it
came to the bible
everything that it touches on
it is true it is true in right so
anywhere that science and history and
archaeology etc appears to contradict
the bible either that is not
an actual contradiction or the worldly
philosophy or perspective is wrong
like that's kind of what i was rooted in
right
and then but i was also very curious and
i constantly sort of rederived my faith
and would go back to the beginning and
because as you get exposed to other
perspectives and worldviews which is
kind of impossible not to in this day
and age with the internet
you continually sort of check yourself
and go back and try to rebuild the
foundation and make sure that okay i
want to make sure that this is
that that i can i can derive this i can
explain this i can communicate this to
myself and others right
but over the course of my adult life i
came to think that
christians might actually have it
backwards i.e when the secular
scientists historians archaeologists etc
questioned the truth of something in the
bible they they most likely were right
right that was the process was it was a
was a slow and steady shift
and then coming to that conclusion which
i finally got all the way on the other
side of that
uh coming to that conclusion gave me
permission to question what i kind of
call the
underlying cosmic principles of
evangelical christianity
namely people are born into a broken
relationship with god and if they don't
reconcile that relationship through
jesus they will spend eternity
in unthinkable torment in hell and
when i started thinking like that's not
even something that i want to believe
um i had given myself the permission to
not have to believe it because i didn't
i no longer believed the underlying
sort of ideas that led to that right and
at that point is when i was like okay
no longer consider myself a christian
and that happened
i can't remember what year i said that
was when i went back to my story but
you know at least several years ago
now a lot of people pointed out that it
seemed like
the two of us were not rejecting
christianity per se but we were
rejecting evangelical christianity
okay right uh and maybe more
specifically
southern evangelical christianity um
and i'll say i somewhat agree with that
um because that is what we had
and that is what we experienced that was
our story
and that is what we rejected but i will
also say uh
that you know i don't think that jesus
rose from the dead
i don't think that god's ultimate true
manifestation is in the person of jesus
um and so i would say that that puts me
safely
outside of the christian camp
philosophically right so yes uh so i
would also say that so i have also come
to
that conclusion that's that's where i'm
at right now that's my thinking about it
um having said all that
i will say that most of what i'm going
to say today is
intended for the evangelical church and
more specifically the
white evangelical church in america
because again that's the world i come
from that's the world i know
that's the world i left and i am going
to say some things that are difficult to
hear
if you are in the white evangelical
church
um and again
i do not say any of this to be like
to like get back at anybody for saying
anything about me again i'm
i'm grateful for the criticism that i
received
i am pretty grateful for the criticism i
will receive for this because
pretty grateful it it continues to make
me
a person who cares less about the
opinions of others which is a healthier
person
and it may be hard to hear this but i'm
not lying when i say that
i say these things out of love and
i say them with a true hope that they
will ultimately have a positive impact
you just have to take my word for it
okay now i haven't been part of the
evangelical church for
several many years it was like six or
seven years probably
but you know before we told our stories
there was a lot of speculation about us
that we might be
still be evangelical christians because
there was lots of public evidence of
that
from our past you could pull it up you
could come to that conclusion
and the actions of white evangelicals in
the year 2020
served as a strong confirmation for me
personally to have publicly
disassociated myself from the church
now again i left because i came to
what for me was an inescapable
inescapable conclusion that the church
had a spurious relationship with the
truth
and i feel like that spurious
relationship with the truth was borne
out in 2020.
but it's more than just a spurious
relationship with the truth i think
the church demonstrated that it has a
spurious relationship
with justice as well
so on the issue of racial injustice
and i'm going to pull some data from the
public religion research institute
this is all shout out this is all
straight from there
white christians are nearly twice as
likely as religiously unaffiliated
whites to say the killings of black men
by police
are isolated incidents rather than part
of a pattern of how police treat african
americans
white christians are about 30 percentage
points more likely to say monuments to
confederate soldiers are symbols of
southern pride rather than symbols of
racism
white christians are also about 20
percentage points more likely to
disagree with the following statement
generations of slavery and
discrimination have created conditions
that makes it
difficult for blacks to work their way
out of the lower class
robert p jones uh who's also associated
with the
prri
created a racism index that was
generated using 15 questions designed to
get beyond
personal biases and include perceptions
of structural injustice
so basically this is a racism test
white evangelical protestants had the
highest median score on the races
racism index as jones summarized while
most white christians think of
themselves as people who warm
who have warm feelings toward african
americans holding racist views is
nonetheless positively
and independently associated with white
christian identity
i don't having spent most of my life in
the white evangelical church
i don't need these stats but you might
need them
in order to understand that racism has a
very
comfortable home in the white
evangelical church
today and
also news flash and people who know
their history
and know that this is uh
this is uh this is not new right it
isn't like 2020
made the church racist the church has
been the white church
has been has held up racist ideas and
defended racist ideas and perpetuated
racist ideas for hundreds of years the
church
contra now what we were told what we
grew up thinking is that you know the
only reason that slavery ended was
because of the christian abolitionists
but what that fails to account for is
the only reason that slavery continued
for so long was the white
protestants who were justifying it and
doing it
right um and and not only that
not only were they instrumental in the
justification of slavery the church was
instrumental in the justification of
segregation that followed slavery
and sunday morning remains the most
segregated time of the entire week
in america 2020 just pulled the curtain
back
2020 just pulled the curtain back on
something that
lots of people have known for a long
time i will say you know you
you kind of alluded to it i'll just say
you know i'll refer to your medium
article
letter to a white man because that's
where you explored
you your own experience and you wrote
the letter to your former self
i think that again you made a statement
earlier that like
if given given my experience
and your experience growing up when we
did where we did including in the church
but just
when we did in general as
white guys um yeah i know a lot of
this rings true for me from personal
experience
and uh you know being close to it to the
point where
i i person i personally am sorry
for being so close to it and unwittingly
involved many times more than i even
care to
reflect or completely understand because
it's scary to think about
um but i talked to my kids about it
you know yeah um so i just wanted to
throw that in there
yeah my this rings true from from my
personal
experience and the reason this is such a
tricky thing
um is because
as a as a white christian i didn't i
didn't think that i had racist ideas
in fact i felt i i had been inoculated
to racist ideas because i
believed in a gospel that was for
everyone there was no slave there was no
free person there was no man no woman
there was no race the gospel it doesn't
discriminate and i thought that because
that was true therefore racism can't
really exist but what i
failed to see until i left was that
so many racist racist ideas
were not being challenged and actually
were being perpetuated within our church
in ways that we were blind to
um but when it comes we come back to
2020
as opposed to being on the front lines
of calling for racial justice in america
why evangelicals reliably
deny or minimize systemic racism
and and they also point out the problems
with racial justice uh racial justice
protests
rather than acknowledging the problems
that are being protested
right what and this is what i talked
about in my letter to a white man
what does a typical white christian
white evangelical christian say about
the protest
ah violence is never the answer that's
that right that's the first thing
a lot of times the only thing they say
but okay yeah violence is not good
we don't want violence violence is not
productive most of the time
but what are people upset about can we
talk about that
no well that's what that doesn't exist
that's what we heard from again if
you're a white evangelical and you're
like well i don't believe that
well a lot of people you go to church
with do
simply put white evangelicals have been
on the wrong side of the fight against
racial injustice
okay what about kovid let's talk about
covid
let me just stop and acknowledge that
for many of you who are already down the
rabbit hole
who have who subscribe to a
a christian nationalism and have mixed
you know trumpism and jesusism together
nothing that i say is going to be
compelling in fact
and everything that i say is going to
just confirm to you
that i have completely departed from the
truth and now live in a world of lies
i'm not talking to you i'm talking to
the person who sits next to you in
church who knows better
covet despite clear evidence showing
that
mask wearing helps slow the spread of
covid
white evangelicals are the group least
likely to wear a mask in public
least likely if you who throw a dart at
a demographic in america who's least
likely to wear a mask
white evangelicals get that award
although the covid mortality numbers are
within the range predicted by scientists
at the start of the pandemic
and hospitals have been as predicted
overwhelmed in many parts of the country
white evangelicals are the most likely
demographic to deny the seriousness of
the pandemic
white evangelicals are also much more
likely than the average american to
question the efficacy of vaccination in
general
and more likely to believe false
information about the covet vaccine
all this has added up to being one of
the key reasons that america has
such has had such a tough time with
covid
in short white evangelicals have been on
the wrong side of the fight against
covid
i don't want to get into too many more
details i'm not trying to give you
evidence and argue if you don't believe
if you don't believe
that kobe's a real deal and you don't
believe in mask or whatever i'm just
saying that
this is what this is what is born out in
america
so in summary uh white evangelicals
largely not all again not all
but largely and more than anyone else uh
represent an intersection of science
denialism and racist ideas that have
made them
an impediment in the fight against both
coveted and racial injustice
and instead of worrying about the poor
and the black and the brown
who are more likely to suffer from both
the pandemic
and racial injustice white evangelicals
have been preoccupied with their own
personal freedoms
spending more time and energy talking
about their own persecution rather than
those actually being persecuted
sorry
i i i don't i'm not exactly sure why i
get emotional about it but i think it's
because
i was such a part of it for so long yeah
yeah i mean yeah i just i can think of
i can see myself there
and so i don't it it
um it hurts and it's him
it's it's embarrassing yeah there's a
lot of shame uh yeah
in it yeah and
again it's just not oh look at how good
look at how righteous we are now look at
how woke we are now
it's just not i mean it's like because
i'm not thinking about
when you say that i end up thinking
about my former self i'm talking to
myself
yeah and it's
yeah but perhaps
the single issue that best captures
white evangelicals dubious relationship
with truth and justice
is their overwhelming allegiance to
donald trump
do i want to talk about donald trump no
i do not i'm so glad
that i do not have to see him in the
news cycle
you probably don't want to talk about
him either but
we can't talk about 2020 we can't talk
about
white evangelicals we can't talk about
the last four years without talking
about donald trump
by far the most reliably supportive
group
for donald trump donald trump holding
steadily at around
eight out of ten eight out of ten
that's a lot you tell me there's an
eight out of ten chance it's gonna rain
today i'm like i'm
bringing my umbrella 8 out of 10
of white evangelicals supported donald
trump
both times around 2016 and 2020
and i can thank a few people not just
presidents
but just few people in general who are
less christ-like than donald trump i
mean
i okay right it's not i'm not this isn't
i'm not being far-fetched yeah he has
enjoyed more evangelical
support than even george w bush who was
actually an evangelical
right and let me just say
again i i hesitated putting this in
there but
listen i'm no longer a part of the
church
but things could have fallen different a
little bit different and i could i could
have
i could still be in the church right if
if the multi-world
theory of the parallel universe is true
there's there's
billions of rats that are still in the
church let me tell you what those
billions of rats are saying
right now well you're annoying them
that's for sure
well no the rhett that is out there in a
parallel universe who is still
in the evangelical church would not have
gone along with this donald trump
[ __ ]
i can tell you that right now
and i lost so much respect for so many
people who did
now for me the most personally
disturbing thing is the way that
christian
talked about this before christian
nationalism and trumpism
have kind of combined to create
something that carries the name of jesus
literally if you look at the capital
protest you see
there's trump 2020 flags and literally
jesus 2020 flags i don't think he was
running for president but you there's a
flag that says jesus 2020
right next to a trump 2020 flag not
uncommon at all to see that
but they've combined to create something
that carries that name of jesus but
looks
nothing like the jesus that i i've seen
in the bible
um journalist carol uh kuruvia
did a good job of contrasting the words
of jesus with those of donald trump so
i'm going to do that just quickly just
take this in jesus said
love your enemies do good to those who
hate you bless those who curse you
donald trump said when people wrong you
go after those people because it is a
good feeling
and because other people will see you
doing it i always get even
jesus said for i was hungry and you gave
me something to eat i was thirsty and
you gave me something to drink i was a
stranger and you invited me in i needed
clothes and you clothed me i was sick
and you looked after me
i was in prison and you came to visit me
then the righteous will answer him lord
when did we see you hungry and feed you
or thirsty and give you
something to drink when did we see you a
stranger and invite you in or needing
clothes and clothe you
when did we see you sick or in prison
and go to visit you the king will reply
truly i tell you whatever you did for
the one of the least
whatever you did for one of the least of
these brothers and sisters of mine you
did for me
donald trump said i'm putting people on
notice that are coming from syria
as part of this mass migration that if i
win they're going back
i could go on about other things you
said that would contrast with that but
jesus said those who exalt themselves
will be humbled and those who humble
themselves will be
exalted trump said sorry losers and
haters but my iq is one of the highest
and you all know it
please don't feel so stupid or insecure
it's not your fault
yeah i'm not laughing that's almost
funny yeah but i'm not
laughing anymore um jesus said do not
store it for yourselves treasures on
earth where moths and vermin destroy and
where thieves break in and steal but
store it for yourselves treasures in
heaven
where moths and vermin do not destroy
and where thieves
do not break in and steal for where your
treasure is there your heart will be
also
trump said part of the beauty of me is
that i'm very rich
okay she actually did a lot more that's
all i'm going to do i could go
on cheating on his pregnant wife with a
porn star then paying her off
bragging about grabbing women by the
[ __ ] uh bragging about being able to
shoot somebody on fifth avenue and not
lose any supporters
again this is none of this is new you've
heard it from so many people i would say
i'd be tempted to say you know what it's
a little late for this isn't it
and that's that's just the shocking
thing is that
it's not there's still so much the
allegiance is still there
right now yeah the allegiance is still
there now
uh listen i know many evangelical
christians who recognize these
quote-unquote flaws in donald trump
but they say that he stands for their
interests
and he stands against something that's
worse than him and therefore
supporting him is justified right that's
the position by by many people
now personally i find it hard to square
jesus words to turn the other cheek
uh with an almost obsessive insistence
that civilians be able to carry an ar-15
i find it hard to square jesus words
about feeding and clothing the hungry
with separating children from their
families at the border
i find it hard to square jesus words to
the rich to sell their possessions with
sup
uh with supporting tax policy that
concentrates wealth in the top one
percent and gives corporations the
rights of individuals
i don't i can't make those two things
line up very well
but even then there are still
people who say listen look at what he
did with the judges he got three
conservative judges on the supreme court
he got hundreds of uh federal judges
appointed
you know good constitutional christian
conservatives and therefore
all in all he's done good even if he's a
bad flawed person
here's what i say to that uh my friend
william matthews
made an astute observation uh about
this desire for christians to
have power uh for their interest to be
represented in the
quote-unquote kingdoms of the world and
in matthew chapter 4
you may remember this story after jesus
had fasted for 40 days satan took him to
a high mountain
showed him all the kingdoms of the world
in their glory and he said to him
all these things i will give you if you
will fall down and worship me
now there's a lot to that story
but the idea is that
satan himself was saying that like i
where i exert my power is in the
traditional kingdoms of the world
and he's asking jesus are you interested
in exerting your power
there and that was the temptation that
jesus said
no to and it seems to me when i look at
white evangelicals in 2021
they have fallen to the temptation that
jesus himself resisted
here's one way to here's one way to see
it if you're a white evangelical in
america in 2021
you're no longer represented by jesus
you're represented by the my pillow guy
i mean that's what i would think
because that's what i see
so again so thankful that i was able to
say that i'm not a part of this group
heading into 2020. but i want to address
another aspect of my
of the story one of the common responses
um to our story was a sense of like fear
and panic that
the two of us were leading kids astray
that these youtubers who have this big
audience
that has a lot of kids in it are causing
these crises of faith to happen all over
the place right
um and that in turn led to a lot of
people talking about how churches and
parents need to do a better job to train
and educate young christians to protect
them
from people like me and you right
yeah um i have an alternative theory
about why so many young people are
leaving the church because they are
leaving the church like never before
i would i i was going to say i'd like to
take credit for it
but i'm not going to say what i'm saying
is i don't think it's because of me and
you and here's why
and i say this don't i mean it i say
this out of love and respect because i
do believe that there is hope for the
church
your kids are not leaving the church
because you didn't train them enough
your kids are leaving the church because
you train them well enough to develop a
sense for truth and justice
you let them read the words of jesus
and they got it and they've recognized
that the church doesn't seem to be
interested in those words
they're not leaving because they don't
know the truth they're leaving because
they do
this isn't even necessarily something
that they would articulate
this is something that is happening on a
soul level
because me and you didn't give any p we
didn't give people new information that
they never considered
there wasn't anything revolutionary
there wasn't anything any even
particularly insightful about what we
had to say on our podcast honestly
nothing that we said was never
it all been said before but i think the
thing that we did is we demonstrated
that it is okay to question
it is okay to question at all your kids
were already questioning it
because it's pretty questionable okay
it is and
now they're seeing that leaving the
church
might not ruin your life in fact you
might find a new life you know when
lando was nine years old
his one of his favorite people on earth
was
his teacher from last year
and um
she's a lesbian she has a wife they have
two kids
we went to legoland and we happened to
run into them
this is before a pandemic hit and
it was you know it i got a kick out of
lando seeing his teacher who he loved so
much
in a different environment you know you
know it's it's
that there's always that that that funny
exchange between a student and their
teacher
out in the wild and it feels weird
but his his love for her was so
strong that it had the power to overcome
that weirdness and like they we got a
picture together
and we would see each other in line we'd
talk to each other and like
you know it was it was amazing just that
he has that type of
relationship with with his teacher if i
would have instilled in him what was
instilled in me
he would have not he
he would have felt deep down within
himself
that he didn't have permission to love
her
i that was my experience you know
because
and and i know that that's you know
that's you can pick that statement apart
easily because like well there's just
there's another thing
yeah but i know what the experience is
like and i know
how i looked at people who were who
weren't straight
um but the thing is and to your point
lando knows
he knows what it's like to love somebody
that that that's not something that is
inherent
it's not something that i had to teach
him and
the fact that he's free to love her
is is a beautiful thing that i
and to love her fully i think i love her
fully because yes when you love
because again i'm not saying that
christians who there are christians who
believe
based on their commitment to the bible
and the what their interpretation of the
bible that being gay
is ultimately wrong but they say that
our gay acts are are are wrong
but the person is lovable and can be
redeemed et cetera
but the thing that that just mentality
work out that way
and you can't in your heart you're
invalidating a huge part of that
person's identity and existence and also
the in your teacher's case the the
relationship in her family
is is not a valid or a legitimate family
and therefore that's not full it's just
not full love and he and i didn't have
to teach him that
yeah right he knows he knows what
what full wholehearted true love for
somebody is
and i'll leave it at that but
so if you want your kids to stay in the
church again this is unsolicited advice
i don't know if anybody's taking it but
it's this is not a
hey i want all your kids to leave the
church that's not what i'm saying at all
if you want your kids to stay in the
church you don't need to change your
kids
you need to change your church
if your kids can't find jesus
the jesus that they know from the bible
the jesus that you've taught them about
if they can't find him within the walls
of your church you know what they will
go
looking for him elsewhere and that may
not be what they say they're doing
that may not be how they articulate it
may not be how they describe it but
i believe that that's what's happening
and it's interesting because
you know people made assumptions about
about me and you and they're making the
same assumptions about their kids let me
explain so
a lot of people assume that we left the
church because there was something out
there
something outside of the church whether
that be fame fortune cultural
acceptance whatever that we ultimately
wanted more than jesus
right like we fell to the temptation and
we went after that thing instead of
jesus
and you also think that your kids might
want something out there something
outside of the church
more than they want jesus i think it
might be simpler than that i think maybe
your kids
who left the church just wanted jesus
and they saw that
you wanted something else
they see that the church at large seems
to want something else
because in my experience
in just looking at it and again
regardless of your conclusions about the
nature of the historicity of jesus
and the specific words that are in the
bible but if you just take
the words of jesus the life of jesus the
teachings of jesus at face value
you have to do some very athletic
very athletic mental gymnastics
to find a way to reconcile the way the
white evangelical church looks in
america today
with any of those words
i just can't put those puzzle pieces
together in a way that makes sense
okay i stepped into a giant pile
of bull crap and we'll see how that
airs out on the internet but let's move
on
okay uh to in in an effort to kind of
finish this up
um with where i'm at spiritually right
um so i've covered some of this ground
but just
by way of just kind of putting it all
together
you know when i was a christian i was
i was obsessed with having it all
figured out like understanding
my faith redriving my faith over and
over again uh
it was a relationship with god
but the way that i fed that relationship
was with knowledge
knowing scripture knowing more truth
teaching that kind of thing
especially in the traditions that we
came in came from you know
it's a very mind-based
tradition sort of the more reformed you
get in the in the white evangelical
church the sort of mind-based
intellectual it gets
and the more you kind of move into more
of a charismatic pentecostal experience
it gets a little bit more heart based
and
i never really had that i went to those
kinds of churches at
times but didn't have that wasn't my
personal experience
um but today
uh i see spirituality as
an openness to things that transcend my
conceptual understanding
but are still deeply meaningful right
um and i think that
most people now some people don't some
people are like i don't need
i don't need faith i don't need religion
i don't need spirituality full
full stop i think that
the majority of people do need something
that they might describe a spirituality
um
and you know religion sort of represents
a human effort to systematize those
glimpses of connection that we have with
something deeper that leaning into the
mystery
um and one of the reasons that it's so
effective at it is that it happens in
community
right the religions religion happens in
community
it's it's like community and culture
together
kind of meets faith and the places where
it's more embedded in the culture and
more embedded in the community the
places where it is the strongest
and like last the longest right
and there's this really interesting
thing that's happening all around the
world but it's happening in our country
as well is that
you know more people are moving into a
new religious category every single year
and that is the religiously
non-affiliated
and there really isn't a community for
that and i think that my prediction
is that those chickens are going to come
home to roost
and uh this idea that everybody's going
to be disconnected and just
religiously unaffiliated is not as i
don't think it's a sustainable way to
move forward and it may take a
generation or two
i don't know before
things come back around and i don't have
any predictions predictions as to what
that is but i kind of
feel myself in that group right now
but as it applies to me personally so
don't start a church no no i'm not i'm
very much not going to start a church um
but as the way that i kind of think
about christianity now and again this is
all like
i'm just kind of opening up my mind and
heart a little bit and just saying that
this these are
this is some of the way that i think
about it today but are you saying
just the point of clarification that you
think that the when you say it's going
to come back around or
to roost you're talking about the church
will change to a point where then people
will be willing to go back in
that that is one of several options
that's one of several options
i'm just saying that i don't think that
religious unaffiliation
is a sustainable condition for the
average
person and i'm not again
that doesn't mean that it means you were
a return to traditional understanding or
traditional religion it might just mean
a
a resurgence in 4-h i'm just saying that
if you ana if you look at the human
makeup right if you just look at the
composition of a person
and you had a way to break them down you
would find
something within them or just it's
something that you would interpret
in the hole that is a
need for a connection with something
beyond themselves
social component well yeah relational
communication
it might be that is that is strictly
biological and it can be satisfied
with human connection alone but i just
don't
for me i think that it feels deeper and
bigger than that
and so but you're saying at this you you
personally are missing
and some inexperience no i know i well
i'm not missing it
uh i'll get into that okay so okay so i
think a lot of people in the west
including me
you know we think about religion in a in
a deeply personal way meaning that we
think about it in terms of our
individual experience our individual
destiny
our individual soul and
christianity is very individualistic
right
and there's a lot of reasons for this
some of it has to do with how much greek
philosophy influenced the writing of
paul
um but it but it's been reinforced over
thousands of years as the west has
become even more and more
individualistic i mean there's
you know the printing press where
everybody had their own bible and that
kind of thing and it kind of the
authority kind of
shifted away from from just a few people
reading
but this personal relationship that we
talk about in christianity it's not
something that you find much in eastern
religion it is kind of a western
phenomenon right there's much more of a
collective sense of identity and also
religious identity in the east than
there is in the west
um but there but there's this other
aspect of the way
greek thought has influenced
christianity and that is this
distinction between body and soul right
and this distinction between god and his
creation it tends to be this idea
of separateness from god in separateness
of soul and body
and then i think that that leads to
continues this dualistic thinking leads
down this road where there's a
distinction between the church
and the world this is just an
observation about
the church and if you don't know if
you're not in the church you may not
know that this
is what most all evangelicals believe
um you know and this is what i believed
which is
the church and the people the christians
within the church literally have the
spirit of god
inside of them and everyone who isn't a
believer is ultimately left to their own
devices
um that's another thing that makes it
hard to validate someone else's
experience
when i believed that i literally had as
you said there's three parts of god
you know the father son and the holy
spirit and when you make that decision
to become a christian the holy spirit
indwells you you literally have the
spirit of the almighty god within you
leading you guiding you and when you're
not a christian
you don't have that and so you're just a
human left to a human's devices and
humans way of thinking
it's one of the reasons that christians
tend not to trust people who aren't
christians
it's one of the reasons that christians
tend not to trust authorities
like you know the scientists and what's
the government up to now and
you know or a plumber without an ichthus
fish on the back of
his truck yeah i mean well it's the see
it is a secret code that
i think does go that deep well there's
god
not always the holy spirit's in your
holy spirit if if i think that i've got
the spirit of god
in me and i think that you don't
how that we're in a we're kind of in a
different place
oh yeah right that that's consequential
i think that's consequential for
humanity and i think it's one of the
reasons that
i think it's one of the reasons that you
can interpret and i do interpret a lot
of the actions of christians in 2020 as
supremely selfish right
you know again regardless of what you
think about a mask
again the whole principle of the mask is
that it's not foolproof but
that it to some degree depending on the
nature of the mask
which is important it slows the spread
of covid
but what does it do it mostly prevents
the spread
from the person wearing it right so it
is a supremely
selfless thing to wear it and it is a
pretty selfish thing not to wear it
right when it comes to the vaccine again
the whole idea of vaccination
is that the collective gets vaccinated
to a certain
rate in order you know individuals get
vaccinated
at a certain rate to protect the
collective
and for every person who says well i'm
going to see what happens i'm going to
see what happens with other people
i'm not doing that again it's you're
thinking
whether you think that vaccines are safe
or not like if you think that they're
not safe you're still
putting your own safety and security
above the collective
because you know that without it what
i'm just saying that it's a selfish act
and i'll even say i mean we're talking
about
having this spirit and then looking at
those that don't and and what that
does deep down i've never thought about
this but i do think it
it does have an impact it it
it alters the equation in how you love
somebody
i mean it's it's something that you have
to navigate
you know it just you know if if you
really think about it
how it how it impacts the nature of
loving somebody and you might say well
yeah i want them to be and dwelt with
this
holy spirit as well and i'm motivated by
that
but there's it's dicey right there's
another side to that psychologically i'm
just
i'm just raising the question we you
know we don't have to we shouldn't get
into it but
i'm just observing that it
it's a complicating factor to
to to to to someone who believes they've
been
dwelt with a spirit to love somebody
who's not
like wholeheartedly and i think that
the thing that i'm seeing is that it's
not just difficult to fully love them
it's more difficult to trust them
i think that that's what we're seeing in
our country is there is an inability to
trust
people who are outside of the church
that's why
it's been fascinating to me that when
you talk to an evangelical christian in
light of 2020
they think that the biggest problem is
that they are being persecuted
they think that the biggest thing is
that there is this socialist
marxist movement that is out to get them
to eradicate christianity from the earth
to literally like if you were to ask the
average
uh evangelical christian like what are
the chances that
being a christian will be illegal in 25
years
i think you would get some i think they
say pretty high
i remember thinking like that i thought
that it was all headed towards this
place where christianity was going to
become
more and more illegal and another
biblical
right and we everybody who's living
always thinks that they're in the end
times of course but
um but really what i'm getting at is
this dualistic
individualistic approach to faith
is something that i have had my feel of
i've did a lot of that right
and so naturally as i kind of move
continue to try to lean into the mystery
and be a spiritual person and move
towards spiritual things
um i'm naturally a lot more attracted to
more inclusive ways of thinking
that focus on interconnectedness of
humans with each other and with
the earth you know with nature in
general uh so that's
what i tend to explore right now and um
and i know that sounds sort of ambiguous
nebulous whatever
um ultimately what i'm saying is that
faith systems that are built on an us
versus them
or it's like i have something and you
need it
versus we've all got something and we've
all got a connection to not only each
other but to something beyond us
uh i feel like not only i'm personally
more
inspired and attracted to that right now
but i also think it's better for the
world
and where we're at as a as a species now
when i told my story i used the infamous
analogy
of uh saying that chris christianity was
the ship
in the ocean and i jumped off of the
ship
into a sea of uncertainty and i dragged
my wife and my children with me
i talked a little bit about this on the
christmas episode about how i regretted
that analogy
for a number of reasons um chiefly
is what it made it seem like i was
saying about my wife i was making it
seem like my wife
and my kids but especially my wife had
no agency
that well whatever the guy decides a
girl has to go along with it it's like
and i regret even implying that
because um my wife jessie
has just go to her twitter account if
you're interested in seeing
uh her exercise her agency
[Laughter]
l-o-s-f-a-m jealous
i hope she adds that to her twitter bio
exercise in my agency
um meaning that jessie has her own story
that i think she she'll tell at some
point
and jessie is uh she is
to characterize what she went through is
some sort of
me leading our family down a a road to
question christianity and her coming
along for the ride is a
is a is a very
large misrepresentation of what actually
happened i may have been the first
person to ask some of the tougher
questions but she has had her own
distinct
journey in many ways much
deeper and more significant than my own
and she's challenged me in a lot of ways
and also
been really instrumental in my own
personal spiritual growth so
it ain't about me leading my family
uh into despair but
i also regret the analogy a little bit
because i didn't fully explain what
um you know
having reflected on it the point that i
was trying to make was also that the
ship
on the ocean of uncertainty that seemed
to have a purpose and seemed to be like
there's a bunch of people on that ship
i believe that was an illusion of
certainty and security i don't believe
that the ship existed
it was just a collective of people who
decided to gather together and i don't
believe that it actually represented the
foundation that
i thought that it did that's why i
jumped
um but i was recently listening and
one of my favorite philosophers is alan
watts
um and
you know he's like a 60s based
writer professor i don't even know
really what his background was
but he's just he's just a trippy dude
who says a lot of things that sort of
expand your mind and make you think
about things differently and i enjoy
um listening to him and just
again just like having my mind kind of
like challenged and expanded because of
the way that he sees the world
and uh i wouldn't say that it's
necessarily a spiritual practice to
listen to alan watts it is somewhat but
for me it's kind of just fun
it's certainly a philosophical practice
yeah right
uh and it is an expansive way to think
and he does talk a lot about things that
i relate to as i
consider where i come from and where i
might be going spiritually speaking
he'll he'll filter the western um
point of view through through taoism
buddhism you know he'll kind of give you
a primer on those well and that's it
so he was talking specifically about
this and he used the same analogy of
jumping off of a ship so or you may set
a rock but what he was saying is that if
you read the bible um the
the analogies used for jesus
and just the faith in christianity is
it's a rock
it's a foundation it's a steady
stable thing that you need to be on you
need to be rooted you need to you know
you need to be planted
in a sea of uncertainty so that you can
kind of withstand all the things that
life would bring at you
and he's saying in contrast to that you
know buddhism
kind of represents jumping off of
that foundation into
a sea of nothingness and he says and the
only way to survive
in the sea of nothingness is to swim and
the only way to swim
is to relax you know if you're drowning
in a in the ocean a lot of people say
that if you can't swim
don't just go you'll sink if you just
start trying to
tread water the most humans float
if you just relax and float
your head will stay above water and
i was like man this is a this is a kind
of this is
a great way to sort of reinterpret and
reapply
my analogy because i don't
feel like i'm in a sea of uncertainty i
feel like
i'm free right i would
i would mostly describe where i'm at
right now
as there is a sense of lightness and a
freedom ironically
that is the way many christians
especially people who have you know you
know
uh we didn't have the privilege of
having like a hardcore testimony like
some people you know every once in a
while when people did testimony time
you got like the guy who was like i was
in the church of satan
and i was a biker and i killed a boy
and then i found jesus and now there's a
sense that a burden has been lifted off
of me
and when you grow up in the church you
don't get that you don't have that cra
i was crazy and did all this stuff now i
got jesus
um but the way a lot of people describe
the moment of coming to faith is a sense
that a burden has been
lifted off of them and there is a
lightness and they feel free
i'm not arguing with that especially if
you've got a background where you
uh you know you were all about yourself
and then you gave yourself to something
else
but i just find that to be ironic that
the for me the the leaving and also
being vocal about my leaving
has been um the sense of freedom
the sense of lightness the sense of not
being burdened the sense of being
open in the sense of not feeling
threatened i think one of the things
that was so true of my experience
as a christian was that everything
was a threat everything was a threat
you think this no well that's i'm that
might be scary
um you might be out to get me you might
be bad for me
i know where that leads yeah kind of a
thing and uh
what i have found is that you know what
when i jumped out of the ship of
christianity into the sea of nothingness
which still may be a bad analogy it's
not like my moral compass
was it was on the ship i think a lot of
people
live with the understanding that well no
the compass is on the ship if you leave
the ship
you don't have the compass anymore it's
like no you still you got it
it's actually unless you're just uh
biologically predisposed to
be a horrible person uh most people
have a pretty intact moral compass and
that sense of truth and justice that
your kids naturally have that your kid
that orlando naturally has and it's been
interesting to navigate the world
in a way that it doesn't mean that my
guard is completely down
i still in fact one of the things that
i've gotten better at recognizing
especially through therapy
is malignant narcissism
uh as someone who is at least somewhat
narcissistic myself
you know it uh when you see it
and but malignant narcissism
and the idea that somebody is ultimately
about themselves above
all things is something that any
organization any system
is a breeding ground for for narcissists
to rise to the top and the church is no
exception
the story of the mega church pastor who
falls from grace which
is just oh you know every month or every
year there's going to be another big
story like that
it's it's a case of malignant narcissism
being rewarded uh in the church
and i think that i've actually gotten
better at recognizing
people who are out for themselves and
people who actually
are a threat to me my family and my
well-being
and then to realize that a lot of the
people that i thought were threats and a
lot of the ideas that i thought were
threatening
are not um and that is
i don't know man i'm just having a lot
more fun as a human
than i did before and that doesn't mean
that i'm
doing a bunch of wild things that would
that would blow your mind if i told you
and
you know compromise who i am and you
know in my marriage
no not far from it and um
but i will say that so so the idea that
christianity is kind of about how
you know it's foundational it's a rock
you kind of got it figured out
and you go from there moving away from
that
into a more open place that doesn't have
a system or a structure
i don't know exa this may be a season
because i also don't think necessarily
that
a systemless way of going about things
spiritually
is sustainable which kind of gets back
to what i just said which is this whole
religiously unaffiliated so i don't know
what this means for me personally
right now it means that i'm reading a
lot of different things listening to a
lot of different things and
um having what i would describe as
significant spiritual experiences
and again a lot of these things are not
things i want to talk about explicitly
they're kind of ineffable and i feel
like you take a little bit of the magic
away from them when you start trying to
explain them and put them into human
words
but i do think that
spirituality is best experienced in
community and i think the idea that i'm
just some
guy who like listens to something on my
headphones by myself
and that's my spiritual experience is
not
the end-all be-all i think one of the
things the church does very very well
is community and i think that we need
community
we need connection and i think that any
true religion any true faith any true
spirituality is going to be about
benevolent connection between people
it's not going to be about hierarchy
it's not going to be about
one narcissistic dude making all the
rules in charge which a lot of
happens in systems a lot of times but
true
benevolence and grace with
from one person to another and like my
wife and i experienced that
you know as we have spiritual
experiences together
but again i think that
ultimately and i don't know when this
will happen but i think that
it's got to happen in the context of
community but as soon as you apply
labels and systems to it
humans get involved and end up doing the
things that humans do which is they
establish the hierarchy they
they reinforce the patriarchy they the
narcissists rise to the top
um so there's some interesting
conversations going on and have been
going on for years about
what does this mean for the church like
if if the church
you know really wakes up from its
uh from the nightmare um and again
there's lots of people who say listen
guys you're just still talking about the
evangelical church or protestants or
you know there's actually a lot of
people who call themselves christians
who are
already where you're talking about and
come be a part of that community
i'm not saying that i won't i'm not
saying that that's not going to happen
um so far i haven't gotten to a place
where i feel like i
could comfortably re-enter that kind of
environment that is
saturated in christian language ideas
and imagery
and not just go back to the
individualistic dualistic way of
thinking about things
so um maybe there's a community out
there where you can kind of experience
the openness and the expansiveness and
it's about connection
with each other and something beyond
your collective self
um that because i'm not interested in
saying hey i'm gonna go be a buddhist
i'm going to go
and be a part of a tradition that i have
no knowledge of and have done and
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think the answer is to go find another
system
or subscribe to some new faith and
become like an inductee into some other
you know what i'm saying like that
doesn't feel right right now
so i don't know a lot of it is a it is
up in the air
but i don't feel an emptiness right now
and i don't feel like this
great desire to immediately
define what it is that i'm experiencing
to e to try to invite other people into
it
i'm not i'm trying not to be
evangelistic about it i tend to be
evangelistic in general meaning that i
try to
share and persuade and i'm trying not to
do that with what i'm experiencing and
probably the fact that
i don't you can't even really put your
finger on what i'm saying about it was
probably helpful to that end
but um yeah that's that's kind of where
i'm at right now
is there's just this anticipation that
um
we're all moving in a direction and
i wanna i you know i want to be where
the magic's at
oh okay that's a good place to end with
magic
uh you're gonna become a magician yeah
right well i
you know what uh we'll thanks for coming
in right we will talk to you again
a year from now i mean how do you feel
at this point i don't know man
okay uh i i appreciate
you know i appreciate you pulling all
your thoughts together and
you know i think you put a lot of a lot
of care into it
and um i i i appreciate the
the honesty and the way that you're
you're processing it and
um yeah i'm here if you want to talk so
much
but i mean to that end i mean
next week uh i'm i need you to hold my
beer
right yep you know i've been putting a
lot of thought into it and i think that
you know as
you've talked about your experience i'm
going to kind of pick up from
from from that spot uh you know
like the last section and just kind of
run with it with
with my own experience and um
just process
you know uh it's it's it's been a
difficult year in a number of ways
so uh dealing with
suffering loss uh
there's been a lot of tests you know
tests of faith
uh i i might call them
i i definitely would have called them
that in the past
yeah um so i
i want you know i want to i've got some
experiences i want to share and process
in you know in terms of my spiritual
journey and
if you're willing to join me that'll be
that'll be next week so uh
i'll i'll i'll give it a go
and you know what like i said we're not
always going to
devote an entire episode to talking
about these things but
um we'll we'll keep we will keep talking
about these things
in in general as well and one and your
words
on the internet about the this
conversation
entering into this conversation are
encouraging
um and again it's not doesn't have to be
encouraging it could be a critique it
could be a question
hashtag ear biscuit just get involved in
the conversation
and incorporate that so that we'll one
it'll be easy for us to find
in my wreck i'll end with a with a wreck
i've kind of already made it and i think
that uh that is going to be alan watts
there's a number of ways that you can
find his work but one of the ways is if
you just go
alan watts is an artist on spotify and
someone i know that his son is involved
in like maintaining his foundation but
yeah that's alan watts.org
and dot com someone has taken some of
his he just did a bunch of lectures that
were recorded somebody has taken some of
his lectures and put them
with music on spotify and again if
you're just looking for a mind-opening
expanding experience
uh it's just a trip to listen to this
dude and the way he
chooses to think about things and
chooses to communicate about them
and i highly recommend it for anybody
who just
is up for that kind of experience all
right you did it
go take a shower or something i don't
know do i stink
no i'm just i'm just trying to just give
you just something to look forward to
okay all right well not lunch
hashtag here biscuit y'all we'll speak
at you next week get ready
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]